la salute nel senso
comune è considerata probabilmente la
dimensione più importante del benessere
su cui si devono misurare le politiche
pubbliche ma lo è anche lo è anche nel
modo con cui la interpretano le persone
comuni
ce lo dice al personaggio della vignetta
ma il personaggio del veneto ce lo dice
anche con un tono un po fatalistico come
dire disparità di salute avvengono un po
per caso e la storia che vi racconto è
che queste disparità per salute non
avvengono per caso sono ingiuste sono i
neri sono evitabili e possono ricadere
sotto la responsabilità di specifiche
politiche questo è quinta quanto vi
proverò a dimostrare e ve lo farò con
alcuni dati che cercano di tracciare un
po l'identikit delle disuguaglianze di
salute per capire se effettivamente è
vero che ci si possa fare qualcosa
partiamo da torino andiamo come in tutte
le grandi città torino
se provate a raccontarla in termini di
distribuzione di reddito vedete che c'è
una forte disparità fra la collina alto
borghese con un reddito molto alto e
nelle zone delle barriere operaia di
nord e sud con basso reddito nelle zone
piccolo borghesi e di classe media un
reddito intermedio ma quello chi vuole o
raccontarvi alla storia di salute la
storia un'animazione non ha funzionato
molto bene per cui ha dovuto ricorrere a
una situazione un po meno efficace tra
mi scuserete questa storia di salute ci
parla ad esempio di aspettativa di vita
voi provate a prendere il tram 3 che
parte dalla collina e va dal lato
opposto della città a nord verso il
quartiere vallette sono come vedete i
tuoi quartieri sono un po agli opposti
per livelli di reddito e vedete che i
personaggi che salgono su questo tram
ogni chilometro perdono circa 4 5 mesi
di speranza di vita all'estremo tra i
due
tra i due quartieri in media e cerca dei
34 anni di speranza di vita ma gli
isolati più ricchi la distanza tra gli
isolati più ricchi di usare di più
poveri arriva fino a sette anni di
speranza di vita
le storie di salute che stanno dietro a
queste differenze sono davvero molto
molto curiosa perché chi sta in questo
quartiere pia praticamente in termini di
speranza di vita è già ai tempi
dell'expo a destra
chi invece sta nel quartiere a sinistra
è praticamente al la speranza di vita e
quindi e condivide l'esperienza di
salute che quelli che stavano in collina
avevano già sperimentato 30 anni prima i
tempi del rapimento moro questa è un po
la dimensione del delle differenze che
ci troviamo nella nostra città perché
perché in quel quartiere si dovrebbe in
quel quartiere quelli che ci vivono
hanno una casa cibo hanno medico
eccetera perché dovrebbero stare così
peggio dovrebbero star così peggio
ammalarsi di più una questione di
fortuna o e una pressione di stili di
vita una questione di inquinamento e dei
rischi lavorativi una questione di
accesso ai medici o una questione di
geni o o è una questione invece di
posizione sociale questa è la la
questione che affrontiamo in questa
presentazione e in effetti se passiamo a
livello italiano andiamo a vedere cosa
succede per titolo di studio
a destra ci sono i laureati e man mano
crescete scendendo lungo la scala di
istruzione arriviamo alle persone con le
elementari a parità di età
il rischio di morire cresce
progressivamente fino ad arrivare a un
eccesso dell'ottanta per cento tra gli
uomini un pochino meno tra le donne
questo è un quadro abbastanza specifico
e ci fa vedere una caratteristica
costante di questi fenomeni
se dalla mortalità saltiamo a un
indicatore di salute soggettiva provate
a intervistare gli italiani
mila 13 con scale psicometriche per
chiedere come sta la loro salute a
parità
se confrontata con gli pari voi vedete
che la media che sta più o meno in
centro di queste differenze vede le
persone di bassa istruzione avere circa
il doppio di probabilità di riferire di
stare meno che bene rispetto ai ai
laureati però vedete che queste
differenze tra le diverse livelli di
istruzione a parità di età vedono alcune
regioni sulla sinistra molto più
complesse nel del divario è che alcune
regioni della destra con un gap
estremamente grati quindi c'è qualcuno
che sa fare meglio di qualcun altro in
questa storia
tornando alla mortalità la stessa cosa
succede su scala europea qua son 21
popolazioni europee dove di nuovo
abbiamo i tassi di mortalità a parità di
età tra le persone di col titolo di
studio della scuola dell'obbligo a in
alto in mezzo all intermedia è in basso
i laureati e vedete che sistematicamente
in tutti i paesi ci sono differenze
dello stesso segno della stessa
direzione ma ci sono paesi a sinistra
che ha saputo fare molto meglio sono i
paesi dell'europa a 15 e paesi a destra
che invece sanno anno
un'esplosione nell'intensità delle
disuguaglianze quindi disuguaglianze
della stessa direzione dappertutto avere
poche risorse individuali fa male a
tutti però di intensità differente se
dovessimo riassumere queste
caratteristiche introduttive in termini
di una specie di identikit delle
disuguaglianze potremmo dire che il nome
sono son disuguaglianze di salute perché
sono disuguaglianze in salute perché
colpiscono sempre di più svantaggiati
potrebbero essere diverse potrebbero
colpire un po gli svantaggiati un po gli
avvantaggiati invece sono sempre a
svantaggio dei più sfavoriti
quando la tata sono praticamente sempre
da quando li misuriamo le conosciamo
quindi da quando possiamo misurarle
conosciamo qua dove capitano quando avrà
il luogo di nascita e residenza in
verità l'abbiamo visto che in ogni
contesto in cui misuriamo però il
contesto può fare la differenza il
contesto può cambiare
l'intensità di questa di queste
disuguaglianze e i connotati i segni
particolari sono che li vediamo legate a
tutte le forme di povertà di risorse
individuali che possono essere quelle
delle competenze questa capacità nelle
espresse dall istruzione quelle delle
relazioni di potere espresse dagli
indicatori di classe e quelle materiali
espresse dal reddito ed alla ricchezza e
infine l'ultima caratteristica di questi
connotati particolari è che sono in
relazione a scala e non a soglia non
esiste una soglia sotto la quale non
fanno male le disuguaglianze ma a
qualsiasi livello di posizione della
scala corrisponde a un livello di salute
migliore di chi sta sotto è peggiore di
chi sta sopra
l'insieme di queste identikit fa sì che
è ricercato questa cosa ed a mettere di
sicuro in galera e da condannare però
siccome noi siamo di quelli che
preferiamo la riduzione del danno e la
riabilitazione dei colpevoli vogliamo
chiederci perché queste nascono perché
se capiamo i meccanismi con cui queste
nascono evidentemente siamo anche capaci
di identificare i punti di ingresso da
cui possono trarre ispirazioni politiche
o interventi di soluzione e allora i
principali meccanismi di generazione
sono di tre categorie la prima è che se
mettete a confronto
l'alta posizione il dirigente il manager
a sinistra e l'operaio di bassa
qualificazione a destra sulla base di
caratteristiche che il maestro di questo
campo d'indagine che michael marmot
della university college di londra
suggerisce che sono in grado di
sbilanciamento che c'è tra che cosa si
esige da una persona e quale grado di
autonomia
si concede nel fare questo compito alla
persona quale grado di remunerazione
quale grado di aiuto gli si offre
vediamo che ovviamente da un lato ci
sono le altre posizioni sociali da cui
magari si chiede anche tanto ma si dà
tanta autonomia tanta remunerazione e
tanto aiuto viceversa ci sono le basse
posizioni sociali di cui non sempre si
chiede molto a volte sì a volte no però
il livello di controllo e remunerazione
aiuta estremamente basso questa è
l'origine di quella che potremmo
definire in basso riassumendolo il
concetto di posizione sociale letta in
chiave di salute cioè fondamentalmente
la posizione sociale è una scarsa
capacità di controllo sul proprio
destino sulle cose che ci succedono
nella vita la prossima settimana il
prossimo mese fra vent'anni e ci
chiediamo questo primo meccanismo che è
la scarsa capacità di controllo che
hanno le persone di bassa posizione
sociale come può agire sulla salute e
può agire con quattro meccanismi
intermedi diretti di azione sulla salute
il primo è quello che è ben studiato in
neuroendocrinologia ed e cioè che questa
situazione di scarso controllo sulla
vita innesca delle catene neuroendocrini
che portano ad alti tassi di quegli
ormoni come il cortisolo libero che
spiegano lungo periodo l'aumento del
rischio di infarto e l'aumento del
rischio di depressione di diabete di mal
di schiena di cadute del sistema
immunitario e delle capacità di difesa e
di riparazione eccetera ora questa
questo fattore di rischio questo stress
cronico che è scatenato da questa cosa
come si distribuisce socialmente e se lo
vedete e gli operai a sinistra hanno tre
volte in più la probabilità di avere
questo rischio rispetto a degli
impiegati già quindi questo è un
meccanismo che intermedia questo effetto
un secondo meccanismo è quello che è lo
scarso controllo che ha la bassa
posizione sociale
e altresì
nocivo per la salute perché genera una
maggiore dipendenza dalle sostanze e
agli stili di vita e insalubri che sono
quelli che poi dopo generano problemi di
salute e vedete a sinistra le differenze
per titolo di studio in italia nel fumo
tra i poco istruiti e molto istruiti e a
destra le differenze nel sovrappeso in
entrambi i casi le persone meno istruite
a parità di età hanno più rischia di
essere fumatori di essere forti fumatori
di essere in sovrappeso e condividere
tutti gli stili di vita a rischio per la
salute come il sesso non protetto e
alimentazione scorretta eccetera
eccetera questo il secondo meccanismo di
mediazione della posizione sociale
sempre la posizione sociale come povertà
di controllo e quindi di condizioni di
subordinazione ovviamente porta a vivere
in posti o a lavorare in situazioni che
sono a rischio per la salute a in questo
caso vediamo qual è la probabilità di
essere di risiedere in un comune vicino
a un sito inquinato ed è circa il doppio
tra i comuni fra chi risiede nei comuni
in meno dei privati a destra rispetto a
chi risiede nei comuni più ricchi a
sinistra quarto meccanismo di
intermediazione è che lo scarso
controllo sul proprio destino sulla
propria vita che caratterizza la bassa
posizione sociale può minacciare la
probabilità e la capacità di fruire di
cure appropriate ed efficaci
torniamo a torino e vediamo il caso
dell'infarto a sinistra c'è l'infarto
mappato sulla città di torino e vede
rivedete le cose che vedevamo sulla
speranza di vita le zone rosse le
barriere operai ea nord a sud sono
quelle in cui ci si ammala di più a
infarto a destra la seconda mappa ci
descrive come è che ci si
rivascolarizzata rivascolarizzazione
coronarica è la risposta efficace
appropriata o un infarto e vedete che le
due mappe coincidono al contrario sono
totalmente dissociate quindi ogni
livello di accesso a un problema di
alla cura una soluzione di diagnosi e
cura ea rischio di mostrare questo
mismatching dove c'è più bisogno c'è
meno capacità di usare le cure
appropriate e questo e un quarto
meccanismo che può generare questa
infine c'è un meccanismo ancora finale
in diretta in verità perché qua vedete i
primi due ricostruiti vedete a sinistra
il bar in basso il basso controllo sulla
vita alla bassa posizione sociale che
genera un aumento di esposizione a
questi fattori di rischio stress stili
di vita rischi ambientali accesso alle
cure tutto questo causa un problema di
salute distribuito this ugualmente come
abbiamo visto ma vedete che questo
problema di salute può ricadere sulla
capacità dell'individuo malato che fa
esperienza di malattia di progredire
sulla scala sociale quindi c'è un altro
meccanismo questo caso un caso di
causazione inversa che provoca questo
effetto
questi tre meccanismi cadi hanno rimesso
in ordine a sinistra in scala questi tre
grandi meccanismi la posizione con la
bassa posizione come scarso controllo i
meccanismi intermedi questi i fattori di
rischio è questa questa caduta nella
mobilità sociale discendente che è
legata all'esperienza di malattia sono
ognuno un punto di ingresso per delle
possibili politiche se guardate il primo
meccanismo quello della stratificazione
sociale dello scarso controllo è ben
espresso dall esempio a sinistra
torniamo in italia noi sappiamo che i
disoccupati in italia nel 2013 avevano
il doppio del rischio di presentare una
cattivi indici di salute mentale
misurati con scale psicometriche se noi
avessimo effettivamente se fossimo in
grado di riportare la salute mentale dei
disoccupati allo stesso rischio della
salute mentale degli occupati nel 2013
noi avremmo risparmiato più di 380 mila
casi di salute mentale
compromessa se su questi 380 mila casi
con un primo colpo di bacchetta magica
le politiche dei sussidi di contrasto
alla povertà nella disoccupazione
avessero funzionati ne avremmo evitati
circa 80.000 se non solo questo ma le
politiche di mobility di politiche
attive del lavoro e di sviluppo
economico avessero riportato la
disoccupazione del 2013 a quella pre
crisi nel 2005 ne avremmo evitati circa
250.000 questo vi dà l'idea di quanto
può essere importante la risposta delle
politiche redistributive quelle di cui
si discute in questa in questa ted
conference nel cambiare il livello di
controllo sulla vita che poi influisce
sulla salute che è determinato dalla
diversa posizione sociale
il secondo gruppo di meccanismi che è
quello legato alla distribuzione sociale
dei fattori di rischio vede
fondamentalmente delle la necessità di
distribuire allocare gli interventi di
prevenzione che evitano questi fattori
di rischio in modo proporzionato alla
distribuzione dell'esposizione se sono
più esposti agli stili di vita i rischi
ambientali allo scarso accesso alle cure
le persone di bassa posizione sociale
bisogna fare interventi di universalismo
proporzionato che alloggino più risorse
in questa circostanza è quello che è
successo nel nello screening
mammografico che effettivamente
diminuisce il numero di casi
diagnosticati stadio avanzato e al
migliora la sopravvivenza
sostanzialmente sulle donne poco
istruite che sono quelle che avevano
meno effetti è l'ultimo esempio quello
sulla mobilità discendente e ben
dimostrato da questo caso questi sono le
differenze di speranza di vita a 65 anni
tra i dirigenti e tra i laboratori
manuali non qualificati se pensate alla
revisione dei benefici per il pre
videnzia lì che si discute al consiglio
alla presidenza del consiglio dei
ministri
per adeguarli all'aspettativa di vita
media è chiaramente intuibile che è
quello che capita è che usando la
speranza di vita media
praticamente gli operai che muoiono tre
anni prima percepiscono la pensione tre
anni in meno in regalano la loro
pensione ai dirigenti che invece vivono
tre anni in più
questo è l'esempio del fatto che si può
fare conosciamo fatti spiegazioni
soluzioni e chiamano delle
responsabilità ci sono alcune cose che
dobbiamo ancora scoprire in questo campo
e non ci possiamo soffermare ma torniamo
all'inizio e concludiamo effettivamente
la salute è importante è importante per
tutti come criterio di benessere
però possiamo anche togliere questa
rassegnazione questa questo fatalismo
del nostro cipputi di turno perché
effettivamente sappiamo molte cose che
chiamano la responsabilità dei decisori
fino al nostro parlamento e qualcuno non
diciamo niente di nuovo qualcuno già due
secoli fa
questo grande patologo che fondatori
della medicina moderna già ci ricordava
che la medicina è una scienza sociale e
la politica non è altro che una medicina
su larga scala è questa un po
l'insegnamento che richiamiamo per
saperne di più c'è questo libro che era
stato richiamato
grazie mille